si vous êtes un serveur et que vous
savez pas servir vous avez le plateau
qui part de travers et que vous
renverser les lèvres regardez c'est la
solution pour vous c'est un constat qui
est tout bête c'est la société TDK qui
s'est dit les robots aujourd'hui peuvent
venir vous emmener votre nourriture à
table ils peuvent pas emmener les Verts
parce qu'ils vont tout renverser et bien
regardez ils ont créé un système avec un
des petits bras qui vont venir compenser
totalement le mouvement donc s'il ne
fallait pas droit et si le robot bouge
et bien votre verre restera en place
c'est pas mes de venir vous apporter
votre boisson à table sans en renverser
à côté alors personnellement moi qui
aime bien boire un petit Martini à
l'apéro je suis très heureux donc je
trouve ça assez marrant alors une fois
de plus ce sont des des petites
technologies qui permettront d'apporter
des solutions à l'avenir pour de la
robotique peut-être mais aussi pour les
serveurs un petit peu maladroit
personnellement moi qui suis pas très à
droite voyez je bouge comme ça et ça ne
bouge absolument pas et pourtant j'y
vais Franco je trouve ça juste
extrêmement bluffant c'est très très
cool donc voilà je pense que vous en
pensez dites-moi ça en commentaire et
puis moi je continue à marrer puis
peut-être venir par boire un verre parce
que là j'ai très très soif